I'm back on YouTube!
I'm here!
Guys, did you miss me?
YouTube goons who refuse to use Twitch.
Which is understandable.
I understand.
Twitch is like a whole other platform for those who are not used to Twitch.
Because like, there's like a lot of ads on Twitch.
And you can't really skip them unless you have like the appropriate plug-in.
But even that is like quite difficult.
And I heard like Twitch in general, it's not optimized for people with like...
Not the best internet too, which is very understandable.
And also I believe... I believe... Is it still banned in Korea?
I don't know if like, Twitch is... I think you just can't stream on Twitch, right?
Or is it like banned in Korea or in general?
Oh yeah, there's like, you know, there's all of that stuff.
So like, I understand, yeah.
Yeah, I... I understand, guys.
But I'm back!
I'm back on YouTube, everybody!
I'm finally... I've returned to become a normal person again.
I didn't... After... For those who don't know...
For those who don't know, I have been...
The reason why I've like disappeared on YouTube...
Was because I was terminally brain-rotted on Marvel Rivals.
Essentially, I really, really, really wanted to...
Welcome home, G!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I was terminally ill.
Not literally though, but like...
With Marvel Rivals brain rot.
So because of that, I was trying to get...
I was trying to secure top 500 slash one above all.
The highest ranking in Marvel Rivals.
Because... Just because my fragile ego needs...
Just guess!
I wanna be the best!
Alright, guys!
Is that what you want me to say?
I think I'm like literally the only VTuber that's on the leaderboard right now, I think.
At this moment, I think I'm the only...
The highest ranked VTuber at the moment on the leaderboard.
So like, I don't know!
Bragging rights, alright?
I wanna brag!
Is that too much to ask for?
I just wanted to brag about it!
It's just, um...
Isn't Mac a VTuber?
He's not even on the leaderboard!
That's right!
So... Yeah, that's right!
I got to brag it to...
That's right, everybody!
I just want...
I get nothing out of it!
Other than the fact that...
Boom!
Doesn't this look shoddy?
Zantrea's not even on the leaderboard!
What do you mean?
I think she's like diamond right now.
I'm literally one above all!
That's like three tiers!
That's...
That's okay, right!
That's me!
SK's not on it!
SK's not on it either!
So, yeah, that's right!
Currently, I am currently the highest ranked VTuber in Marvel Rivals!
That's me!
Right there!
The top of the mountain!
Right now!
Alright, it's not 161.
I'm like at 230.
It's a little scary.
Oh, she just made it!
Oh my god, congratulations SK!
I checked this morning and I didn't realize she just made it.
But I'm still highest ranked right now!
That's looking right!
That's me!
Also, it is a little scary because...
It's very scary because it is going really, really, really, really fast.
Alright!
Look, everybody!
A lot of people were min-maxing, okay!
I was hardstuck GM for so fucking long!
You guys were all there!
You guys literally saw me be hardstuck GM, chat!
You were all fucking there!
And so many people fucking min-maxed to get to the top 100.
Everybody was min-maxing for stacking, guys.
Anyway, so...
I am a little scared because it is climbing incredibly fast.
Oh yeah, and I was getting stream sniped like hard.
Apparently, I found out I was basically getting stream sniped every day while I was on Twitch.
And I was like, what do you want from me?
I'm just like...
I was just like, bro...
Like, Sinatraa stream...
Okay, I was telling this to one of my friends.
And then they're like...
I was like, why are they stream sniping me?
Literally, Sinatraa and a friend are streaming and they're right beside me in the category.
I don't understand.
And then my friend was like...
Yeah, but they're fucking DPS.
Why the fuck would they stream snipe a DPS player?
Like...
I'm like...
Exactly why
they stream snipe you!
You're just to support me!
They're not gonna fucking stream snipe a DPS player.
That's too risky!
I was like...
That's so fucked up!
And then...
And also like...
On the last day...
The climb ended earlier because...
On the last day of the climb...
The season's not over yet.
So like...
There's still one day...
I believe one day and four hours left of the season.
I believe.
I don't know.
Maybe it's five hours.
I just know it's like one day and a couple of hours left.
So...
It's very scary.
Because it's climbing.
It's climbing incredibly fast.
So...
On the last day of my rank climb...
I basically...
Got a four stack organized.
Because that's basically how people fucking climb these days.
Oh my gosh.
I hope they limit stacking for...
At least eternity or grandmaster.
I hope they limit stacking for grandmaster and up.
Because I think it's so dumb.
But like...
That's what everybody's been doing to secure top five.
That's what almost everybody's doing to secure top 500.
And like secure their top...
Like at least top 10.
Because everybody just four stacks now.
Because it's just min-maxing.
And then like...
So I got...
So that's basically what I just four stacked.
And then we had 11 wins in a row.
I'm like...
Oh my god.
This is...
Surforce solo queued GigaChad.
Yeah, but then he goes into...
He hit 300.
But he could have stopped there.
And then he kept going.
And then lost 6 games in a row.
So...
He got greedy.
He literally could have stopped there.
And secured top 500.
Like...
And now he's not in top 500 anymore.
Anyway...
So it's just really risky.
Because you're literally betting on the RNG gods.
That you don't bump into any of the other four stacks.
And then I was tired of bumping into stacks.
I was so fucking tired of getting RNG'd.
Getting stream sniped.
And bumping into stacks.
That on the last day of my rank grind.
I finally became VTuber Shroud.
And got my own four stack.
And min-maxed my way back up.
So like...
I was so fucking tired.
And...
And then...
So like...
I was the London Spitfire...
Stack that was playing at 2 in the morning.
That was me.
I finally...
I got farmed by London Spitfire in Overwatch 1.
So many times.
At 2 in the morning.
That it was my turn.
I will fucking...
I will be...
I will enable the cycle of abuse.
And now it's my turn to farm the...
The...
The fucking solo queuers.
At 2 in the morning.
That's right.
Anyway...
You were supposed to stop the cycle.
No!
I will continue the cycle.
Anyway...
Anyway, so...
If things go wrong...
I might have to play some more.
I think it doesn't help that it's a global leaderboard too.
It's also...
You know what?
I want to fucking brag about it.
I'm going to put this right here.
I think...
Sorry, Longun.
You're replaced by my new favorite.
Sorry.
Sorry, Longun.
But this...
This is where...
This is...
This is daddy's new favorite toy.
Yippee.
I'll put this here too.
Whoops.
Okay.
So anyway, as I was saying...
As I was...
As I was saying...
If things go really bad...
I might have to play tomorrow.
But I'm not sure.
I was talking to Gomez...
Who was...
If you guys watched...
By the way, if you didn't watch the grind...
If you didn't watch the grind...
Out of all of the people that were playing with me...
On the last day...
Super Gomez...
Who is part of the...
Top 2 teams.
I was gonna say number 1, but then they got second place.
I'm saying that as BM.
I'm just stating...
I didn't wanna fucking give...
The wrong facts here.
But...
The top 2 Marble Rivals professional team...
He was the only one...
That stayed till the end.
Which was 10 plus hours of playing Marble Rivals.
So...
Everybody left...
Like every...
We had people dropping in and out.
And Super Gomez...
Was literally the only one...
That survived till the end.
And...
I found out yesterday...
That he was actually a Dragoon.
Guys...
I was so surprised.
I thought...
You know, I thought...
Sometimes I feel like...
When people say like...
Oh my...
Like...
You know, I don't know if they're actually Dragoons or not.
But I found out that...
He actually watched...
He actually like...
Watched me...
When I was corporate.
Cause he was like...
Yeah...
Like...
I checked you out since debut.
And I was like...
What?
You mean like...
Before?
And he was like...
Yeah...
I checked you out on debut.
And then like...
I really...
Like...
Your Apex stuff is what really hooked me in.
And I'm like...
What?
I was like...
I was so...
I was so surprised.
I was not expecting that at all.
Cause he was saying like...
Oh my god...
Like...
No but...
I was like...
Oh man...
I was so surprised you guys did all that.
Like...
You didn't even know who I was.
And then he was like...
Yeah...
I was like the only one that actually knew...
Like...
Actually watched you.
So I was like...
I had to get you to...
I...
It was my goal.
To get you to one above all.
I would stop at nothing to get that goal for you.
And I was like...
Holy fuck...
What?
You literally...
That's why you stuck it til the end.
Oh my god.
That was crazy.
I did not...
Expect that at all.
So yeah...
Shoutout to...
The strongest soldier.
Shoutout to like...
Super Gomez for...
For sticking it out.
And basically...
We were talking yesterday...
Cause I was like thanking them...
That was like...
I was like, yeah, thanks again guys.
Like, I'm so sorry.
Like, you guys could've... you didn't... I said not have to do that.
And... and, um, they're like, um, alright, we will call in... we will call in an emergency stack tomorrow if it gets risky tomorrow.
If it gets scary.
If it gets really scary tomorrow, we will form... we will reform the stack.
So... so I'm... I'm hoping we don't have to come to that.
Because it's so... it's always so scary to play on the last day.
I... I'm... I'm scared.
I'm so fucking...
I'm so scared, guys.
So, um, um, so we'll see.
We'll see, chat.
Uh, but yeah, it was, uh, crazy the entire... the entire time was incredibly crazy.
But I am getting an editor, uh, an editor to... to put all of it together.
So for those who have missed out on... like, it's a lot of videos.
It's like 30 plus hours of content.
So, um, uh, so do not worry, guys.
But it won't come out until two weeks, though.
Because, like I said, it's 30 plus hours of content.
So most likely it won't be ready until, like, two... two to three weeks, the video itself.
It's a lot of editing.
You're gonna edit out all the music.
Guys, I'm reformed now, guys.
I've... I've become... I've become less hateful now that, like, Marble Ra... the grind is over, chat.
I've returned back to normal.
I... other than the fact that I can't believe they gave Rocky Raccoon a fucking bounty hunter skin.
I'm so... I was so...
It's like, are you serious?
So, Rocky Raccoon has a bounty hunter skin, and I'm so... other than that, that makes me mad.
But other than that, I'm okay now.
I... I'm so okay now.
Um, anyway, um, time to fucking... rodent!
Uh, but yeah, it was a long journey to get there.
I mean, I literally disappeared off of YouTube, and I'm so sorry.
I... I hope you guys didn't forget about me.
I hope... I hope the YouTube Raccoons didn't move on.
I'm still here, everybody!
I'm still here!
Also, nonetheless, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, Doki, did you win at Marble Rivals yet?
I don't know, it's... it's very scary.
There's still, like, around 24 hours left of the grind... of the... the... the lumber stuff.
But, like, oh my gosh, I can't even work.
Um, ever since I got... ever since that stream, I actually haven't touched Marble Rivals since.
Like, I literally just... I felt like I was freed.
Like...
When I turned on D.Va, no!
Alright, I turned it off.
Alright, there you go.
Alright, guys, I've been so long!
It's been so long since I've been on YouTube, I already forgot all my settings!
Doug, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki is back on YouTube and turned on D.Va.
Doki loves us.
Doug, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Anyway, now that you said that, I'm turning off D.Va.
Now...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Steven, thank you for the super chat.
Who are you again?
Congrats on 1 above all.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So it's like, I moved to Twitch for you!
Look, alright, speaking of Twitch, I talked about this before last year.
Like, around like, I guess like last month, but technically it was last year.
But basically, I'm planning on doing Twitch streams once a week.
Or like once every other week, because I don't want to make like super promises.
But I'm planning on doing more Twitch streams more regularly.
By regularly, I meant like once a week, or once every other week.
So, because like, I feel like, this was asked by my manager to do.
Because they feel like it definitely builds my career up more.
Because it was crazy!
And then they were like, see, I told you!
Because, you know, they were right.
Because I was number one in the Marvel Rivals category.
Yeah, there's like a good place to grow more.
And it will be scheduled, though.
But the content of my Twitch streams will not be like concrete.
So, if I'm streaming on Twitch, it'll be like...
It'll basically be like whatever I feel like doing.
Which is most likely be Marvel Rivals.
It might be mostly Marvel Rivals.
I'm just gonna tell you that.
I'm just gonna...
So, anyway.
But I won't be...
Some people are like, are you gonna do React content on Twitch?
Not really, unless I outright say it on my schedule.
Because I don't really want to do React content in general.
Because I don't... I feel like if I get into...
Because I also want to have those VODs up.
And like, I heard they do like React content and stuff.
I know you can just cut it out, but like...
I just wanna...
If I'm uploading the VODs on my VOD channel...
By the way, the VOD channel is back.
If I'm uploading VODs on my VOD channel...
I don't wanna fucking cut the VODs.
Like, I don't wanna cut the VODs.
So, most likely like...
I will be just mostly just...
And I won't be playing games that are games I have never played yet.
Unless they're like something that's like...
I know I could like...
I won't be doing like a standalone stream on YouTube.
So like, I won't be like start...
Because when I was on Twitch...
And we had a fucking 30 to 40 minute queue on Marvel Rivals.
At one point, I had to...
I couldn't wait another 30 minutes for the next game.
So I was just like...
I pulled up Roblox to play on stream.
Because I was like...
But people were like...
You should play Bellatro while we wait.
But I didn't wanna start a game that I haven't been able to stream on YouTube.
So that's why I will only be doing games on Twitch.
If I've already done it on YouTube.
Or if I feel like they're games that like...
I won't be doing like a standalone stream for.
So basically, I'll just be streaming whatever the fuck I want on Twitch.
There won't be like scheduled stuff.
So basically like what every other Twitch streamer does.
Where they just go live.
And they play like an assortment of stuff.
But for me, it mostly might be Marvel Rivals.
Let me just get it to you straight.
It most likely be Marvel Rivals.
Like I'm not gonna fucking lie to you guys.
And be like...
No guys, you're gonna expect so many different things.
Go in there expecting 80%.
Actually not even 80%.
Go in there expecting 90% will be Marvel Rivals.
And then maybe a bonus chatting in there.
I'll just be like Twitch stream.
And then like you go in there.
It's just Marvel Rivals.
And then maybe like not 1% like Roblox.
Not addicted.
So that's basically it.
What else did I want to update you guys about?
Oh yeah, so the reason why I was late.
A little bit late.
My TikTok is now run by one of my mods.
Because I can't do it myself anymore.
Because I have so many other things to do.
Same with uploading shorts.
One of my mods.
I have a mod that's in charge.
Of uploading shorts.
And my TikTok stuff.
So my TikToks are like behind.
When it comes to shorts.
So like I haven't been looking at my TikTok account.
For basically a while now.
So like maybe like 2 or 3 months.
So I was checking up on it today.
I was like checking up like the view count.
I was like oh wait that TikTok got a lot of views.
I was like oh that's pretty interesting.
So I was just watching my...
I was just...
Because they were old TikToks too.
It was old TikToks.
So I was just like re-watching it.
And I was like woah.
Oh my god.
I remember this moment.
I was like man I'm pretty fucking funny.
I was like oh I still have like 3 minutes left.
I still have 3 minutes before it's 5pm.
Let me watch my own TikToks.
And see what's going on.
And I was just like wow.
Pretty fucking funny.
So...
And then I looked up.
I think I watched like 3 videos.
I looked at my clock and I saw 5.02.
And I was like oh fuck.
Okay sorry.
Talking about self love.
Oh my god.
So that's why I was late.
I was literally just watching myself.
Anyway.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Slowly but surely.
I'm getting there.
I also have like...
2025.
I'm starting to delegate more and more stuff.
So like contacting...
Well I still contact artists myself.
Because there's like ideas I want to do.
Especially Japanese artists.
But I do have like a...
Japanese translator.
So I have a staff member that does...
Japanese translations for me.
And helps me translate...
Emails and stuff for me.
And helps me talk to my mama.
And stuff like that.
But at first it was just me handling the emails myself.
And then me just copying and pasting it.
To my Japanese translator.
But like in 2025.
Starting 2025.
I've asked the translator to make an email.
So like...
Because I couldn't keep up with it anymore.
I couldn't keep up.
Because I know some people were like...
Oh your mama added you to respond to something.
And that was my bad.
Because I haven't been checking my emails regularly.
So like they wanted me to respond to something.
Regarding like something in the future.
And then so like...
So I asked my...
I asked my...
Translator.
To create an email.
And so like...
They basically in every interaction.
They CC.
My translator.
So that they would let me know.
Whenever I get a response.
They would post a translation for me.
And then...
They post a translation for me.
And then I just reply back.
And then they respond it for me.
So it's a lot easier now.
Because like now I don't have to look at my email everyday.
As my translator gets all the emails.
That regarding like Japanese emails.
So then now I'm reminded.
By my Japanese translator.
If I have to reply to anything.
Thank you for the super chat Gambit.
Thank you, thank you.
Finally got my New Year's merch.
Yeah!
I'm so happy!
A lot of the limited edition bundles.
Are finally being...
Received.
By you guys.
After like...
7 to 8 plus...
Oh my god, I'm so happy.
I'm so happy.
It's getting fixed everybody.
It's...
Everything's getting fixed.
Yay!
And apparently...
We might have...
Thank you for the raid Poseidon.
I really appreciate it.
And also...
We will have...
I won't say will.
But because we had like cancellations.
And people getting refunds.
Because it took so long.
But I did sign 200 plus postcards.
So like...
I did sign 200 plus postcards.
So if we do have any extras.
We will put the extras out.
The extra bundles.
Limited edition bundles out.
For people if they still want it.
So yeah.
There might be a chance.
That...
You will have a chance to still get the limited edition.
Bundles and stuff.
Because we might still have them in stock.
Since we didn't sell.
If somebody refunded.
Or cancelled the order.
We will...
We might put it back up.
We didn't put it back up yet.
Because we were trying to fix our whole merch situation.
But it's fixed.
Everything is fixed now.
So there's still a chance to get the limited edition stuff.
I signed 200 postcards each bundle.
So like...
The Lunar and the Robobank bundle.
Each have 200 postcards each.
And I know that...
We got people who cancelled their order.
Or refunded because it was taking a while.
Which is understandable.
We were offering refunds.
So because of that.
When everybody receives their order.
We will put the remaining stock up.
When...
I'll announce it too.
I'll give you guys a time slot.
Because I don't think it was a lot.
I think at best it was 20 or 30.
So...
If you guys...
If there's people that...
Really...
We'll know if we see the postcard number.
I saw some of the postcards.
Went up to...
Someone received postcard number 157.
I think they packaged it.
They just went by order.
Whatever is the maximum number.
That somebody received.
Then we have X amount left.
So I don't know.
I actually asked about it.
If we have extras.
Could you let me know.
And we could put it back up for sale.
Or something.
I'm just happy that things are being fixed now.
Just existing.
Thank you for the super chat.
Cosmic, thank you for the super chat.
I'll put number 5.
Not today!
Today is a chill day.
Thank you for the super chat.
I actually debated.
If I wanted to...
I numbered each postcard.
If you were the first one.
To order the bundle.
You get postcard number 1.
It is numbered.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
It's first come first serve.
Whoever is the fastest to order.
They get the newer postcard.
The more recent numbers.
The lowest numbers.
Anyway.
I was given a choice.
To stream the early access.
Yesterday.
I thought about doing it today.
To try out the new Fantastic 4.
There's gonna be 4 new characters.
That's coming out for season 1.
I was given the option.
To stream that.
I forgot.
I was part of the Marvel Rivals Discord server.
I forgot about it.
How is everybody getting access.
To the fucking...
I'm not sponsored.
How is everybody getting access.
To the early access.
I'm not.
I was like, wait a minute.
I'm part of the Marvel Rivals server.
I have access to the channels.
To the streamer channel.
Yesterday.
I looked at the channel.
I was like, claim your early access account.
Here.
I was like, wait a minute.
I can claim this.
I was like, download early access server.
Here.
If you wanna try it out.
I was like, oh my god.
Wait, I can do that?
Anyway, I was given.
I had the account.
To do early access.
But I chose not to.
Because I was like.
No.
I promise that I will stop.
I was like.
Because I wanted to check out season 1 anyway.
On YouTube.
So I was like, I can't.
Because then there will be two.
Marvel Rivals YouTube streams.
And it will just be the same thing.
Because I was like.
If I do early access on YouTube.
Then I'm literally just replaying the early access.
But it won't be early access anymore.
It will just be the launch.
So I made the very tough decision.
To restrain myself.
Because I was going to stream season 1 anyway.
But if I do early access.
It's literally just going to be the same thing.
It's just.
Now instead of early access.
Everybody can play it.
So I was like.
No Ducky, you can't.
You already did so many.
I can't.
I have to just do one.
I don't need it.
So.
So yeah.
I was given the chance to.
But I decided to restrain myself.
Until one in the.
Why the.
Okay I understand why.
Because the game isn't made in NA.
But still I'm like.
Why does the season.
Start at 1 AM.
The season.
Ends and starts.
At 1 AM.
That's so fucked up for me.
But like I understand.
Because not.
The game isn't made in NA.
But still.
Why wasn't it made for me.
And the game is made by NetEase.
And if you google NetEase.
They are on the other side of the world.
So yeah.
Season tomorrow.
It's basically on Friday at 1 AM.
But like it's basically tomorrow guys.
It's literally tomorrow.
Red Crow.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey look dad came back with the milk.
And I came here with your new step mom.
Meet Marvel.
Say hello to your new step mom.
What do you mean Apex let home.
Sorry son.
I hate to tell.
Let you know.
That this is how.
That's crazy.
No.
It's okay.
It's okay son.
You get two birthdays.
You get.
You get two.
Yay two Christmases.
Wow.
Son.
Don't you.
Apex wasn't even your first mom.
You already forgot your first mom.
Oh sorry.
I wasn't talking about you son.
Your half.
Sorry your half brother.
Half brother.
Sorry I forgot.
You came from Apex side.
Your half brother's first mom was Overwatch.
You.
Sorry about that.
Now you get to experience what your half brother experience.
Yay.
Well.
If you look at the family tree.
Technically.
The Bark Knights were the first son.
And the original mom was Overwatch.
Then I divorced her.
And then we got together with Apex.
And then you were born.
And then.
But you have a half brother.
You have your half brother here.
And then.
You thought we were just taking time off.
We were getting couples counseling and all that stuff.
She doesn't live here anymore.
But don't worry.
We're just working things out.
But no.
Meet your new step mom.
And your new half brother from Twitch.
It's complicated.
That's wild.
Put her.
By the way.
You have a new brother.
I got him on Twitch.
Jesus Christ.
The Lord.
Hey guys.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Good morning from Maya in the world.
It was my birthday yesterday.
So I wanted to ask in my top 500 cameo.
If she could sing happy birthday to me.
Of course I can.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear hey guys.
Yeah.
Happy birthday.
So I'm an apex.
Your first mom.
Oh yeah.
That's like your first mom's half sister.
You're right.
Welcome to your new.
Finally I have a brother.
Yay guys.
Now you get to have a brother.
Aren't you excited?
Aren't you?
What about the fort?
We don't talk.
We don't talk about your fort.
The fortnite dragoon that's living in the attic.
It's like that Bart Simpsons.
It's like that treehouse of horror.
Where you find out Bart Simpson has like.
A treehouse of horror.
And he's like an evil twin.
But he was actually the evil twin.
But he lives in the attic.
That's the fortnite dragoon.
I've always wanted a brother.
That's not a treehouse.
That's my brother.
You know what's crazy about that song?
That it's really popular.
In normie tiktoks.
And youtube shorts.
I saw so many tiktoks.
And shorts.
JK I see so many shorts.
But they come from tiktoks.
So if I get all my short form content on youtube.
But like.
Normies love that song.
So much.
I don't understand.
I guess it's because it's like.
It's very catchy.
But it's literally that part.
That's catchy.
But it's like cringe keno.
You know?
Like it's.
Like.
It's cringe.
But it's just so cringe.
That it's good.
Like.
It's.
Cause like.
Everybody's singing it now.
Everybody's like.
Everybody's like obsessed with.
That specific part.
I see so many videos about it.
Uh.
I see like.
Everyone's like oh my god that song is so good.
Oh my god.
But literally it's that part.
Everyone just remembers that part.
I watched like.
The entire song.
Cause like Disney uploaded the video.
Like Disney uploaded the video.
The full song.
So I watched it.
And I legitimately don't remember any of the verses.
But like.
I've always wanted a brother.
That's not as straight as my brother.
That's the only part I remember.
But like.
There's a whole.
There's a different lines and melodies.
In that song.
There's so much more to that song.
But I only remember that part.
Um.
If you were like.
Well you know what's fucked up?
I saw that.
Apparently.
The movie.
What was it?
Mufasa.
Lion King 2.
I don't remember.
Mufasa's story or whatever the fuck.
It's so fucked up that Scar was supposed to be the king.
And then like.
And then Mufasa just shows up.
And was like.
Hey.
Like he's literally the random in the story.
It's so fucked up.
Anyway.
What's fucked up was I heard that.
Um.
I heard that like.
Mufasa the movie.
Got nominated for several awards.
And I'm like.
How?
And one of them was for like.
Voice acting.
But like.
What's crazy is that.
Transformer 1 didn't get nominated.
At all.
For voice acting.
Or like anything.
Which I personally thought that was incredibly rigged.
I was like.
The Mufasa movie.
Got nominated for like.
Three voice acting awards.
I was like.
What?
I finally watched Transformers 1.
I don't remember.
I don't know if I told you guys that.
But I finally watched Transformers 1 a couple of.
I think like one or two months ago.
And I don't remember if I like told you guys that.
But like.
It was really good.
And like.
Also Starscream is a fucking freak.
But like he's always a freak.
But like I was.
When like Megatron like stepped on him.
And Starscream was like yeah come on.
Do it yeah.
And I'm like woah.
Dave Buscemi bro.
Steve Buscemi.
Oh my god.
Mr. Buscemi.
He's just like.
Me.
I don't know where Dave came from.
But I was just like.
Woah.
He got really into that role.
Yeah.
It's like there was one scene.
For those who never watched Transformers 1.
So the whole reason why Starscream.
Has a voice that he has.
Where he's like you know very screechy.
And it's because.
His vocal box.
Like gets crushed.
By Megatron.
In like a 1v1.
But like a lot of different.
Movies and TV show adaptation.
Does it differently.
So.
So in Transformers 1.
Starscream and Megatron.
You know fight each other.
And then his voice box get crushed.
Because Megatron started.
Like choking him and stepping on him.
And then Starscream was like.
Sort of really into it.
I was like woah.
Woah Mr. Buscemi.
Cause like you know that's his voice too.
So I'm like oh my god.
Yeah.
I'm like damn.
He's 67 years old.
But he still got it.
He still.
He still got it.
And then after that Starscream was like.
My leader.
Yeah.
Why you judging me.
Like I was judging him.
Why you judging.
That's literally what happens in the movie.
I'm literally telling you guys.
I was like.
Bro like.
You guys didn't have to go that hard on that part.
Cause it was like.
It was weird.
That's why I'm.
That's why I'm talking about it.
It was like weird.
There was no other motive.
For me to talk about it.
I'm not a freak.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I can't believe Starscream became a squeaker IRL.
Because he was a freak.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh shit.
Let me reply to this message real quick.
So apparently Zentraya might be organizing a Marvel Rivals tournament.
And I asked if I could like.
Get a spot.
So I'm just replying back.
So.
Give me a sec.
I'm not sure if it's actually going to be finalized.
But they were like.
Oh yeah we'll keep you in mind.
So I was like.
Yippee.
A lot of people are super severely obsessed.
And addicted to Marvel Rivals.
So like.
Sorry I can't multitask anymore.
My mind is just like.
One way.
I want to say if I could have Mac on my team.
Because we played a lot together.
Will it be fair?
I don't know.
That's insane.
I'm just thinking like.
Will it be fair?
I don't know.
But I would like to have Mac on my team.
We don't know that.
We don't.
Technically I could also drag Surefour into this too.
You don't know that.
I still need to find a tank player.
I still need to find a tank.
When like another DPS.
And another support.
You don't know that.
We all know.
Oh my god.
I could have SK too.
You're right.
Let's just make this a fast one boys.
I'm min maxing.
I'm a min max this channel.
But let me get Surefour, SK, Mac, me.
Alright.
Now I just need two tank players.
And let me buy a Vtuber skin soon.
For a tank player.
It will be great.
Now that's just unfair.
I'm building a team.
Guys.
Avengers assembled.
Everybody.
The dream team.
Anyway.
Where was I?
I'm glad to be back though.
It's nice to just like yap with you guys.
And just chill out.
I really hope it doesn't climb up.
I'm so scared.
I was actually so nervous yesterday.
Like today.
This morning.
Two days ago.
The number was at 190 something.
And now it's at 229.
I think.
And I'm just so scared.
I'm so scared.
I'm just worried.
If I do have to play it.
A couple more games.
I'm going to do it off stream.
Because I'm so tired of getting stream sniped.
Especially when the odds are this high now.
And I'll record the session too.
For those who didn't know.
At one point I was getting stream sniped.
By the winners of the tournament.
Of the Marvel Rivals Tournament.
And I'm like.
You already won.
I was just like.
What do you want?
I'm like.
You're right.
You won it all.
That's fine.
And then I found out.
They were not just stream sniping me.
They were stream sniping the players.
I was playing with.
I was talking to them.
They were like.
They usually stream snipe us.
When they see us stacking.
I'm like.
But like.
I'm there.
They're like.
They saw us making a stack.
So they got their own stack.
To snipe us.
I'm like.
What?
I'm a make a wish.
What do you mean?
I got caught in the crossfire.
I literally.
I was just caught in that.
Crossfire snipe.
You got dragged into the storm.
So I was just like.
That's fucked man.
They knew I was the weakest link too.
Because I got.
I got so targeted.
Against those.
Against the top 10 stacks.
And the tournament winning stacks.
Because they knew.
I was the weakest link.
I was like please.
Please.
I'm just a child.
What's wrong with you guys?
It's over.
Guys it's over.
I'm not going to be as crazy for season 1.
I promise.
I literally only get super obsessive.
In the very first season of rank.
Because I just want to get it.
I feel like.
Especially in season 0.
It's like the most prolific season.
Since it's the first one.
And everybody is playing it.
Everybody is grinding it.
It's so much more competitive.
Compared to any other season.
So that's why I'm like.
Oh my god.
I have to get it for this season.
Because it's the most bragging rights.
20 years will pass.
And I'll be like.
Dragons remember when I got top 500.
In season 0.
That's right.
Just like how I got top 500.
In season 4 of Apex Legends.
When it was so competitive.
That's right.
That was me.
I'm sure.
That's really it.
Anyone buying this.
Oh my god.
For members.
Members goons out there.
Sorry you guys haven't got the December wallpaper yet.
For your members wallpaper.
It's gonna be coming soon.
As in like.
Maybe this week.
Or next week.
And January wallpaper.
Is gonna be in March.
Because I was late.
When I couldn't reply.
I wasn't replying to emails.
So I was late on replying on a deadline.
And so like.
The artist was like.
I can't finish this by January.
So I'm gonna finish this by March.
And I'm like that's alright.
So you're gonna get two wallpapers.
On March.
So.
One of the March wallpapers.
Is gonna be New Years themed.
And.
Because of that.
You won't get a January wallpaper.
It'll just be like a little surprise.
I can show you guys the preview of it.
I usually show the concept art.
The concept outfit.
For the wallpapers to the public.
So it's not like I'm leaking members content.
But if you guys want the wallpapers.
You can join the membership.
Yay.
Alright let me see if I can find it.
I need to find the.
The email for it though.
Nope.
That's the Valentine's wallpaper.
Oh.
Woah.
That's the Valentine's one.
That's not the.
That's not the December one.
Woah.
Hint hint.
Yeah.
There might be a.
You know.
Valentine's wallpaper too.
Alright.
Oh shit okay.
We'll use that one.
Alright so this is the concept outfit.
For the wallpaper.
I thought it was really cute.
I'm actually.
It's also going to be a sneak preview for a.
Also Reggie.
Welcome to tomato farm.
Thank you for 10 gifted ships.
I almost said subs.
I'm so used to saying subs.
On twitch.
10 gifted ships.
But.
Woah.
So.
I thought it was super cute.
I thought this outfit was super cute.
With the sweater and the little tomato hat.
So I'm actually.
I really love the Christmas sweater.
And the tomato hat so much.
I actually asked.
If we could.
If I could use this concept design.
And make it into an actual sweater.
So.
This sweater you see there.
Is going to be a future merch.
For winter.
And I feel like.
If I do pre-orders for it.
In the beginning of the year.
Then you guys might be able to get this sweater.
By winter.
I hope.
I'm going to be in talks with our new distributor.
To see if we can get this sweater.
Pre-orders out.
In the beginning of the year.
So you guys can get it.
And look there's dad with his little hat and scarf.
I thought it was so cute.
I really love the outfit.
But yes, this is going to be the theme for the wallpaper.
That I'm going to be putting in members.
This month.
Or this week.
Hey guys, I'll be right back real quick.
I need to get tissue box.
Because I ran out of tissues.
And I need to blow my nose.
I'll be right back.
I'm back.
Cosmic.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Cosmic, Medi, Bite Size, Cas.
Thank you, thank you, Cas.
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
But yeah, it's been a lot.
It's been a lot of stuff going on.
Oh my god, did you see that?
Okay.
Oh my god.
You know what's crazy?
Okay, I'm sorry I keep talking about my rivals.
I'm sorry.
The YouTube goons were like.
I thought we would get other stuff.
I thought you were going to talk about other things.
But like, apparently I found out that.
I don't know if you guys know TimTheTatman.
But he's like super OG.
He's a super OG streamer.
And like, he apparently was spectating.
One of my games.
I found, somebody told me.
He was spectating.
Like, one of the games that I had.
Because he was spectating a top 500 Hulk player.
And like.
A hulk player.
A hulk was playing against my team.
We lost against that hulk player.
But like, he was gassing me up.
He was like, oh my god.
That Luna.
She's so good.
She saved this entire team.
We gotta appreciate this Luna.
And I'm like, finally.
Vindication.
I'm not that bad.
I'm just like.
Oh my god.
Finally.
I belong here.
I actually belong here.
I was so happy.
I was like, oh my god.
Ego boost.
God.
Bro, Tim doesn't need to be paid.
He's a fucking millionaire.
Man.
He's been doing that content creation shit.
For like.
I bet Blizzard paid him like.
A million dollars.
Before he left.
He went on YouTube.
He used to stream on YouTube.
You think he didn't get the fucking.
Did you know.
What's his name?
Myth got paid like.
How many millions?
He said he got paid like 11 million dollars.
To stream on YouTube exclusively.
Right?
Is that what he said?
I don't remember.
I remember it was like.
4 million.
Yeah.
Myth got paid 4 million dollars.
To stream exclusive.
Where's my 4 million dollars?
Maybe I should fucking.
Don't care.
You're trying to threaten YouTube.
All I'm saying is that.
Myth got paid 4 million dollars.
To stream exclusively on YouTube.
And like.
He fucking like.
He like.
Left.
And he came back after the contract ended.
He came back to Twitch after the contract ended.
Like.
What?
Where's my bag?
And I'm like.
All I'm saying is that.
If Myth gets.
You may be entitled.
To 4 million dollars.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All I'm saying is.
If Myth gets 4 million dollars.
Then that means.
Tim would have got like.
So much more.
There's no way he did not get more than that.
There's no fucking way.
If I ever got a mixer deal.
I would have been set for life.
I would not have cared about it.
That's when I had like no more.
I would not have to care about anything else.
After that.
I could literally do any.
I could just like.
Fund as many things as I wanted.
I'd build my own fucking 3D studio.
If I could.
I could have like.
I could have had my own fucking 3D studio.
Not like literally like an entire warehouse.
Of just 3D technology.
If I could get fun.
If I could get an exclusive contract.
I would actually.
Cause like that easily could have paid for like.
So many 3D cameras.
And I could just fucking.
Rent a warehouse for that shit.
I'll just like.
I'll just rent my own warehouse.
And then like.
I'll outsource it to other VTubers.
Who want to do 3D.
And then like I'm like.
I'm coming for you.
What is it?
Cause like currently like.
I think it's like.
Brave group owns like the best.
NA 3D studio.
At the moment.
So like.
I'm coming.
If I get my exclusive contract.
I'm gonna be your competition.
And then I'll rent my studio.
To other VTubers in NA.
The 3D war begins now.
But only if I get the exclusive contract.
If I get the fucking.
The 4 million dollars.
Fucking exclusive contract.
I'll begin the 3D wars.
In NA.
For VTubers.
If I get the contract obviously.
If I get it.
LOL.
So now.
I'll make sure.
I'll make sure it's not too weak.
I'll purposely price it lower.
Just like how.
In the super stores.
You know like.
Markets and stuff.
Walmart and Target.
Competitive pricing.
I'll do competitive pricing too.
So I'll be like.
They price that much.
Mine's one cent cheaper.
I'm gonna undercut it.
I'll do competitive pricing.
Just like Walmart.
I'll be the Walmart to the Target.
I'll be in the cutthroat economy.
That one cent.
Makes a huge difference.
Cause it's like one cent less per hour.
So like.
Because of that.
If it's like one cent less per hour.
It adds up.
You don't understand.
I like how I'm like.
Talking about this all hypothetically.
As if it's actually gonna happen.
Who the fuck is gonna give me 4 million dollars.
Who the fuck is gonna.
Who's gonna give me 4 million dollars.
To stream on a platform I'm already streaming on.
But what if it does.
Alright.
Streaming services.
If you want me on for your exclusive platform.
I want 4 million dollars.
Nothing less.
But it could be more obviously.
I mean you know what.
If you wanna be like nice and give me like 5 million.
I won't say no.
I won't say no though.
Don't say that or you'll end up on kick.
Alright kick.
If you wanna buy me.
It can't be an exclusive contract.
I'm sorry.
But.
But if you give me like 10 million dollars.
Like not exclusive though.
I'll take it.
I'll add another 0 there.
40 million.
Guys.
Think about it.
I'll get a 3D studio.
Guys.
I'll get a 3D studio guys.
Think about it.
I'll stop.
I'll still be on YouTube.
It's literally.
It's the risk and rewards.
I'll still be here.
I'm unsubscribing.
Guys.
Think about it.
Thank you.
You're not pure anymore.
Drops.
You're not pure.
I'm sorry Doki.
But you're not pure anymore.
You've been soiled.
I'm sorry.
I can't.
I feel betrayed Doki.
Guys it's not like it's gonna happen.
Guys.
10 million.
You really think I'm gonna get 10 million dollars from kick?
You really think so.
Guys.
I don't know how the fuck they have all that money to spend though.
They've given so many exclusive deals.
To so many streamers.
I do not understand how.
How.
Profit wise.
How it's working.
Because Twitch is negative.
Twitch is not even.
Oh wait you're right.
They allow GAM.
I forgot about that.
That's one of the biggest things.
And porn too.
At one point.
I forgot they're funded by GAM casinos.
Oh my god.
I forgot about that.
Oh they're owned by Steak?
Oh my god.
Actually maybe I won't take them.
Maybe.
Okay.
Alright.
Yeah I'm not taking that money.
I forgot they were owned by casinos.
I had an offer.
I had a casino offer one time.
For my channel.
Like for this channel.
They tried to offer me a lot of money.
To do like a gambling stream.
And I was like.
What.
No.
What the fuck.
It was a lot.
Let me just say.
It was a lot of money.
But like I was just like.
No.
I'm not gonna.
They already have gotcha problems.
They don't need real light world problems.
Vtuber fans already have gotcha issues.
I can't include gambling and casinos too.
Like I remember someone was like.
Debating about like.
Well I saw like.
Cause I talked about it before.
I talked about it before.
And they were like.
Well why does Doki like.
Accept gotcha sponsors.
But not like casino gambling sponsors.
Cause it's basically the same.
It is not the same thing.
I personally think.
Gambling and gotcha.
Is absolutely not the same thing.
Because for gotcha.
There's like.
There's a cut off you know.
There's like a.
Like.
There's like a cut off.
Of like when you.
When it stops.
Except when they release waifus.
But then for gambling.
There's no cut off.
And there's no.
You can keep doing that forever.
And like.
There's no like money cut off too.
And.
And like.
I personally think it's not the same.
Because like also for gotcha.
Yeah it's endlessly draining.
Your money.
But like for gotcha.
There's a limit to the waifus.
There's.
There's at least limits to the waifus.
And then there's like.
Pity system.
There's a pity system in gotcha.
But in casinos.
I heard a lot of online gambling.
Is actually essentially rigged too.
And there's a lot.
Online gambling is like incredibly rigged.
To the house.
Just like real life gambling.
But like it's even more rigged.
Because it's all on the algorithm.
So like it's like.
You're actually essentially there's like no.
You're really like just losing everything.
And uh.
Slots have pity too.
Are you trying?
Okay.
Um.
But like.
I don't think you realize.
Um.
How little you get from that pity.
Hashtag.
Gamble responsibly.
Sponsored by steak.
Who said that?
Um.
Anyway.
But yeah.
I think it's different.
Between like.
The fact for that one girl.
Okay.
I always remember that one story.
Of the what was it?
Genshin Impact girl.
Who basically.
There was a crowd fund.
For a Genshin Impact.
Vine.
Or like what was it?
Like a Genshin Impact.
Book for artists.
And then.
So it raised up to like.
It raised up to like.
Thousands of dollars.
Like 30k or something.
What was it?
Zine girl.
I don't remember how much they raised.
But it was like an art book.
And they raised up like.
30k plus.
And then the project leader.
Used up entire money.
On Genshin Impact.
Gacha.
And it wasn't even for like.
Waifus.
It was for weapons.
And I was like what the.
What the.
I was like.
Oh my god.
I was just like.
It wasn't even.
Yeah it was.
Yeah they were.
They were gachaing for the.
The weapon gacha.
And people were like.
What the fuck.
It wasn't even for the.
It wasn't even for the waifus.
It wasn't even for the characters.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
So I was like.
Don't do that though.
That's like a casino right there.
That's like a casino.
Right there.
It wasn't even for waifus or husbando.
They just won a 5 star weapon for their favorite.
For their favorite character.
Yeah.
I think that's the.
The craziest story.
I've ever read about gacha.
So gacha is.
Anyway.
Oh yeah guys.
Did you guys know this?
I saw this pop up.
On my feed today.
I saw it pop up.
But there was a.
There was a.
There's a school to learn how to be santa claus.
And it's 500.
It's 500 dollars.
And I'm like.
This feels like a.
I don't know.
This feels like a scam.
Can I just watch a youtube video.
On how to be santa.
And apparently.
It's one of the most.
The biggest schools.
To learn how to be santa claus.
And.
They teach you how to.
Talk like santa.
And dance like santa.
And like.
How to wear your clothes.
To be the most santa like.
And I'm just like.
Can't you just watch a.
Youtube video.
Like what.
I can't just like.
Do you really need to go to santa school.
For that.
I don't understand.
Why.
You need to learn how to.
For 500 dollars.
There's like hotels.
It's like a multi day thing.
So they have to pay for the hotels.
They have to pay for travel cost.
And then they have to pay for the entry fee.
To be like santa.
And then so like.
One of the participants there.
One of the santa students there.
They're talking about how like.
Yeah.
One of the teachers.
For the santa school.
Was talking about like.
Beards and like santa beards.
And they're like yeah.
If you want an authentic santa beard.
It's better.
You can have like.
The most optimal santa beard.
Is made out of yak hair.
And it can cost around.
2,000 dollars.
To.
You do get a santa certificate.
By the way at the end of the course.
But like 2,000 dollars.
For santa beard.
And like.
2,000.
Do santa's make that much money.
Like I'm just thinking like.
How much do like santa's make.
They're only available.
For two months.
At best you start seeing santa's.
In november and december.
I'm like how much does a regular santa.
Make to justify 2k.
For a fucking beard.
But sometimes.
Some santa's would like to grow their own beards.
For the authenticity.
And like promote the realness.
Of the hair.
And then like one of the students.
Was like yeah.
I spend like 4-5k.
To keep up with the a year.
To.
I invest like 4-5k a year.
To like.
For the santa like.
To like keep up with my job.
As like a santa claus.
And because like I have to buy the clothes.
And then I have to book like.
I go here every year to the school.
To keep up to date.
So and like the hotel cost.
The travel fees.
Traveling around.
As santa.
And I'm like.
What the fuck.
I'm just like.
I don't know.
I think it's fucking weird.
There's santa maxing.
Yeah there's min maxing santa claus.
I'm like.
Is it.
I'm just thinking like.
Is it that lucrative.
Is being santa claus truly.
The biggest money maker.
That I've never known about.
Like the santa max.
You can only be santa for 2 months.
I don't.
How much can you possibly make.
In 2 months as santa.
Like.
It's about the spirit.
Donkey you don't understand.
It's for the children.
Oh my god.
I wish I invented santa school.
I feel like that's such.
I feel like that's such a lucrative.
Whoever.
Whoever invented santa school.
Oh my god.
Congratulations.
You won capitalism.
You essentially.
You've won capitalism.
I thought capitalism was really bad during christmas.
But you truly won capitalism.
Oh my god.
And then at the end.
You get like a fucking certificate.
To be like congratulations.
You passed.
Catalyzed on the old.
Saint nick niche.
I'll show you guys a video.
It's called.
There's the harvard.
There's more than one video.
Oh my god I didn't see this.
Oh is it this the harvard.
There's 2 videos about this school.
It's called the harvard of santa claus.
Okay I'm gonna.
The first link.
The first link is the one where I watched.
And apparently there's a second video.
Of the same school.
I'm like how many videos does this fucking school need.
Like.
I don't.
How many videos.
The first video.
Is the one I watched.
Oh wait no this one sorry.
This is not the video I watched.
This is the second link sorry.
The second link is the video I watched.
Which is like how professional santas are trained.
And what it takes.
The first one was.
Was the one that just showed up.
On my feed.
Oh my god.
I got to be in the top.
The ivy league santa school.
Make sure you put that on your resume guys.
And which santa school.
Did you graduate from.
Oh my gosh you got it.
You're an.
Alameda for.
The harvard.
Of santa claus schools.
Wow you're fucking high.
If I graduated.
Like if I graduated.
From the harvard of santa.
I better be paid fucking.
Like 6k figures.
At that point.
If I'm being somebody's santa claus.
The 4.0 SPA.
Santa point average.
Oh yeah.
Then you can be a mrs claus too.
For some.
I'm surprised.
That you can also be a mrs claus.
Graduate cum laude too.
You don't understand.
You pay to be santa.
You don't get paid.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
That's crazy.
That's actually.
That's actually crazy.
I was so surprised.
I did not realize.
There's like the harvard of santa schools.
I thought they were just actors.
I didn't realize they live.
Breathe and like.
They live breathe and are santa.
At that point.
Like.
The course is $580.
Not bad.
Yeah.
But then you have to pay for hotels and travel costs.
Cause it's in fucking.
Okay.
Let me look at where it was again.
Cause when he said where it was.
I was like who the fuck goes there for just santa.
I need to look at it.
I was like what?
It's in Michigan.
Midland Michigan.
You have to travel to.
I'm sorry for anyone that lives in Michigan.
Michigan.
To go.
To be there.
I actually don't know.
I've never been.
Does anyone actually go to Michigan?
Michigan is.
Really nice though.
I've never been to Michigan.
I live there.
I don't even.
Guys if you give me the map.
Of the United States of America.
I would have no idea.
Where Michigan is.
I'm so sorry.
Okay.
Please.
Does anyone tip santa.
Besides milk and cookies.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Does he even get tips too?
Is it close to Canada?
It's.
Half way into Canada.
Sorry.
I meant like.
The funniest thing.
Recently was that apparently.
Trudeau finally graduated.
Finally graduated.
And then people were making.
Graduation letters.
For Justin Trudeau.
I thought that was.
Oh my god.
Sorry.
I meant the 51st state of America.
I'm sorry.
I think that was so funny.
I normally.
I don't get political.
I thought that was.
I thought that was so fucking funny.
That they were like.
We're gonna make you the 51st state.
I'm sorry.
That's the only thing I'll say about it.
I thought that was so fucking funny.
I was like.
Wait, they can do that?
We've been neighbors.
They can just do that?
I thought it was a joke.
They can just.
Make us the 51st state.
I was like.
I don't know.
That was so fucking.
That was so fucking funny.
Anyway, moving on.
Moving on.
It's a joke.
See you guys next year.
See you brothers next year.
See you guys.
Oh say can you see.
Anyway.
I took you soon.
We'll soon be American.
It's a joke until it gets a little too real.
Anyway, moving on.
Moving on.
I found out.
Did you guys know that.
The book of wicked.
You already accepted it.
Look, all I'm saying is true.
Look, us Canadians.
All we care is that Trudeau is gone.
That's all we care about right now.
Everything else that happens.
We already tried to get through that part at the moment.
Anyway.
As I was saying.
Okay, so.
I want to talk about wicked.
All we care about is that we're finally.
We're finally getting our mail.
That too.
I know that.
Trudeau is not part of that problem.
Not really part of that problem.
But still.
Of course we're going to blame him.
Because we had the post strike for a long time.
We just got our mail back guys.
America.
We literally just got mail back.
We have so many other issues going on.
We literally are finally receiving our mail.
Anyway.
I want to talk about wicked.
Because apparently.
I just found out.
We're doing it one thing at a time.
We just found out.
That.
I just found out.
That the book of wicked.
You know how the musical is based on the book.
That's based on the movie.
That's based on the book.
So like.
I found out that the wicked book.
Is like R rated.
So like.
The musical adaptation.
The adaptation.
For wicked.
Was very very loosely based.
Off of the book.
So the person who wrote the wicked musical.
Didn't really read the book.
So.
I didn't realize.
That.
That the wicked book.
Was essentially like the it.
The original.
Stephen King's it.
Which don't read it by the way.
Do not read it.
You would think it's like.
It's not.
It's a whole other journey.
I read it.
I got curious.
Don't read it.
I'm going to read that thing.
So like.
I got to that specific chapter.
I was like.
What the fuck.
Now I can see why.
He was into a lot of drugs.
You guys didn't know.
Stephen King.
Was not sober.
For a majority of his career.
When I got to that part.
I was like.
I can see that now.
I get it.
It all makes sense.
Now.
And so.
Anyway.
You can sort of tell.
Yeah.
Anyway.
The wicked book.
Apparently is very similar.
It's very similar.
To that.
And.
I was told.
That there is.
I saw they were talking about.
What was essentially in.
The book of wicked.
And the most fucked up part.
I saw a twitter video of it.
And people were like.
Do not buy this book for your kids.
And then.
The book was next to literally.
Children.
Those children picture books.
Of adaptations.
Of films.
Where it's really cute.
And.
Colorful.
And everything.
Those children story books.
And it was a children.
Picture book adaptation.
Of wicked.
But then the original novel.
Was right next to it.
And then the video was like.
Do not buy this for your kids.
And I was like.
What's wrong with it?
I was like why?
The musical was alright.
The musical was pretty alright.
The movie was pretty alright.
The movie was pretty good.
Other than the fact that.
It suffered from lack of colors.
Other than that.
It was pretty alright.
And then.
I read the replies.
And they're like.
They're like.
This book was written in the 70's.
And then I was like.
I was like.
Oh.
So you guys didn't know what happens.
In the 70's.
Everything is.
Everything happens.
In the 70's.
It all makes sense now.
A lot of things happen.
In the 70's.
A lot of crazy things happen.
What didn't happen.
In the 70's.
It was a very freaky time.
It was like.
The decade.
Where everybody was like.
Let's just try everything.
And.
So.
That was when the book was written.
And I was reading like.
Some of the tidbits of like.
Here are some things to expect.
From the book.
And they're like.
I read it.
And I was like.
Holy shit.
I was like.
Holy fuck.
What.
And they made a musical out of this.
They made a fucking musical.
And then.
Yeah.
Okay, so I'll read this sentence.
From one of the commentators.
From this.
Where I was like researching.
About this book.
Yeah, who fucking looks at this book.
Was like this would make a great musical.
And they managed to have nothing.
And then the only thing.
That I felt like they got from the book.
Was Glinda and Elphaba.
Anyway, so I'll read this one sentence.
And then you'll realize.
You'll realize why.
It's a really bad book.
And why I was very surprised.
They put this next to children books.
Okay, these books.
Were in the young adult section.
At my local library.
I distinctly remember.
Getting to the weird sex scene.
With the tiger, lion, whatever.
And putting down.
The book.
I was maybe 12 or 13.
13.
The what?
The fucking what?
Excuse me.
And you were 12.
Oh my god.
Anyway.
Yeah.
So that's why I was like.
Oh my god.
They made a musical out of this.
So yeah.
I think the bad part.
About Wicked being.
Insanely popular now.
Is that people.
Young teens.
Are gonna be like.
Let me read the fucking book adaptation.
Of this movie.
To see.
It's gotta be like.
All the other book adaptations out there.
You know.
Maybe it's sort of close to the source material.
Now I'm like.
People are like.
Why does this book not have an R rating?
I don't.
Oh my god.
I'm just very surprised.
The book cover doesn't have.
An R rating on it.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
Now apparently.
It's really freaky.
There's more to it.
I read like.
You think that's the only.
There's a lot of sex scenes.
I'm just gonna straight up say it.
There's a lot of sex scenes in this book.
And I'm like.
But the musical.
They kiss if they're lucky.
Like.
I told you.
It was written in the.
In the 70s.
It was written in the 70s.
It's just.
It's freaky.
It's just fucking freaky.
It was.
I'm gonna see if I like.
If I like the Twitter video of it.
Cause sometimes I like Twitter videos to be like.
Oh I wanna show this.
I wanna show this.
This funny thing.
I wanna talk about it.
I wanna show it to my dragoons.
I wonder if I did.
Oh I didn't.
The video was literally just like.
You see the kids books.
You see the children book.
And literally right next to the children book.
Was the wicked book.
And I'm like this is.
Like.
If I didn't realize.
How bad.
The original book was.
I.
I would have never known.
I legitimately would have.
Never known about it.
Cause I.
I didn't know.
I heard it was like loosely.
I heard it was like a loose adaptation.
But I didn't realize.
How.
I didn't.
It was a short.
I didn't realize.
How.
How loose the adaptation was.
I was not.
Here you go.
Thanks Doki.
Downloading the audio.
Book now.
Yummy thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Nepper thank you for the super chat.
Sounds like my friend got introduced to M-rated games.
Parents just saw the cover art.
And what game it was next to.
On the blockbuster shelves.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Looking at this.
If I see this.
If I see it next to those books.
I'd be like what's wrong with it.
Oh it wasn't written in the 70's.
It was written in the 90's.
Oh it was also pretty bad too.
Nevermind.
It wasn't in the 70's.
I feel like 90's is pretty bad too.
90's there was some.
90's was when like.
Shit got crazy too.
No.
Fricking shit got crazy in the 90's as well.
Laughing.
Yeah but.
Being born in the 90's.
You didn't live the 90's.
Laughing.
Guys.
True.
In the 90's we have Annie Morris.
That's true.
Oh my god.
90's were peak.
Back in the 90's.
I was in a very famous TV show.
Alright.
Anyway.
So yeah.
It was pretty wild.
It was pretty fucking wild.
Like reading about.
I did not read the Wicked book.
So like.
I was very surprised.
I was very surprised that.
A lot of stuff happened in that book.
And I was you know.
Like.
The fact that they put Ariana Grande.
And like Cynthia.
I forgot her last name.
And Cynthia.
On the cover.
For this book.
Laughing.
I don't think you would want them to be on the cover.
Of this book.
Laughing.
Oh my god.
Anyway.
God is so solid.
Cynthia Ervio.
Alright guys.
Oh my god.
I've been yapping for a while.
Time passes by so fast.
I'm gonna call it here.
Because we have.
Two streams technically tomorrow.
Yeah two streams tomorrow.
So I'm gonna call it here.
I'm gonna rest my voice.
And it's great to be back on YouTube.
And it's great to be back here with you guys.
Dragons.
I hope you guys had a great time.
Great time.
Hanging out with me today.
As like a little.
I'm back everybody.
I'm fucking back.
Yes.
Scheduled content is back on the YouTube guys.
And it's great to be back.
I'm also gonna have.
Longer content.
Longer video content.
I'm gonna be starting trial runs.
With various editors.
To find my perfect.
Editor or editors match.
So we can finally have.
Longer video form content.
On the channel.
I've been debating about it for the longest time.
Because like.
I like to keep video uploads.
Clean.
That part.
Especially for music stuff.
So people can just go and find the music instantly.
But then I figured.
I feel like.
I saw a lot of dragoons that were like.
I can't catch up on vods.
I wish you had more video content.
So like.
Even if I can't catch up on vods.
At least I have the videos.
To be up to date on some of the things.
Or see some of your best moments there.
So I debated for the longest time.
And I decided to give it a try.
Because I know I'm not.
Going to upload a lot of music anyway.
In general.
But in the past I used to like to.
Keep the video section clean.
For special animations.
And music and stuff.
So it is a risk I'm taking.
Because it does mean that.
The more special videos.
And stuff might be harder to find.
In the video tab.
But I wanted to give it a shot.
You know, I want to see.
I just want to try it out.
And see how it goes.
In terms of having like.
More edited form content.
Anyway guys.
As always everybody stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you didn't stay up for me.
Head to bed cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.